again for the stars of England's
dramatic victory in the Cricket World
Cup gongs were always on the cards in
the New Year's Honours List there were
plenty among them in OBE for Ben Stokes
and an MB for Joe rout extremely proud
but it's just an honor to play cricket
for England and is very humbling more
than a thousand people have been honored
including Sir Elton John receiving the
highest of awards Companion of Honour
the Queen's drummer Roger Taylor bears
an OBE and a dame hood for Olivia
newton-john best known for her role in
grease but recognized too for her
charity work once upon a time in an old
stone room
for children of the 70s and 80s floella
Benjamin was a much-loved face on a rare
program just for them now the Baroness
can add a dame hood to her list of
titles
I never imagined appearing on place
we're taking you through the round
window to square when the arch window
that I'd be speaking up for children the
way I've had done over the last 40 odd
years who would have thought that I
could do all that and people would
listen to what I had to say I'm so
thrilled to receive this honour because
of that and an MBA has been awarded to
TV presenter Gok Wan
seen here in how to look good naked for
services to fashion and social awareness
when that letter came through I thought
my god what am I gonna wear
and I don't know yet I think it's
probably gonna be black because I always
wear black and hopefully I want to take
my mum which would be incredible so I
think I'll be styling my mom and getting
my mum prepared and I'll probably be a
last minute thought but obviously
something very smart because for June
Sarpong
regular presenter on the Sky News
program the pledge there's an OBE and
elsewhere in Sport England footballer
Jill Scott receives an MBE although
she will award I would like it to be for
the whole of women's football I think a
playing great teams and that's obviously
why I've got this recognition but yet I
see the journey of women's football
especially from when I started out it
was always difficult it was always new
and a lot of boys and you always have
proved yourself whereas now I think it's
accepted that it's normal for girls and
boys to play football so for that I'm
very pleased another sports woman to be
recognized is World Taekwondo champion
Jay Jones with an OBE but nearly
three-quarters of this year's recipients
have been honored for their work in
their community like 27 year old Mehta
Coburn who receives an MBE it's so
important a young people at a heart of
democracy and you know the charity that
I run my life might say there's a huge
and vital part and making sure that our
voices are heard particularly in some of
the biggest challenges are facing
society the youngest recipient is only
13 Ebrahim Yousef receives a British
Empire medal after raising thousands for
charity there's always some controversy
and questions are being asked about the
Dame hood for former Director of Public
Prosecutions Allison Saunders criticized
over her handling of rape cases but it's
the stars of stage and screen that many
will be looking out for this year's list
has plenty of those Emma virtually Sky
News